[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je devais définir notre invité avec
un mot un seul je choisirai la constance
que vous écoutiez ces interviews passées
ou présentes vous verrez qu'il ne dévie
jamais de sa ligne de conduite ni de ses
principes déterminer à portée dans son
art de chanteurs compositeur et
interprète un discours d'exigence de
respect et d'indépendance d'esprit
exigeant il est avec ses textes d'abord
qu'il s'isait dans les tintendo et de
pudeur respectueux il est avec son
public à qui il refuse de proposer des
titres moyens ou bâclés juste pour
occuper l'espace de la chanson française
quant à être indépendant d'esprit ou
indocile comme le dit l'un de ses titres
c'est l'un de ses combats face au
discours préfabriqué face au courant de
penser à la mode face à ceux qui parlent
beaucoup pour ne rien dire à tous les
micro que l'on veut bien leur tondre
dire ce qu'ils pensent sans jamais dire
aux autres quoi penser il est là son
point de rupture avec le monde dans
lequel nous vivons est-ce pour cela
qu'il a choisi de vivre loin du
microcosme Paris bien est-ce possible
d'être un artiste à succès et de refuser
les codes imposés par le milieu posons
lui toutes ces questions bienvenue dans
un monde un regard bienvenue Bénabar
merci d'être avec nous ici dans ce dôme
tournant du Sénat merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation est-ce que vous diriez
que vous jouez effectivement une
partition dissonante dans le monde de la
chanson française
j'oserai pas le exprimer comme ça parce
que c'est très flatteur mais je suis
assez récalcitrant et même un peu malgré
moi de devenir une forme de de porte de
drapeau d'une d'un discours qui est pas
exactement dans
qui correspond pas toujours à celui
qu'on veut entendre ou qu'on entend
beaucoup trop parce que ça veut pas dire
c'était une confort à vous je crois que
ça dans un dans une émission l'autre
fois il y a une différence entre
visibilité et représentativité c'est
donc il y a des gens qui sont très
visibles ce que vous disiez sur ceux qui
ont beaucoup de micro mais qui sont pas
forcément représentatifs de beaucoup de
gens et c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours
considéré que c'était essentiel de faire
de la tourner notamment on sait bien que
Paris c'est pas la France mais encore
faut-il le vivre et je le ressens
d'ailleurs depuis quelques années
beaucoup plus cette différence entre un
microcosme parisien de plus en plus
resserré
vous le décrivez la réalité vous la
décrivez cette parisienne vous dites
factice corrompu vérolée il faut avoir
un réseau avoir les bons contacts plutôt
qu'une bonne chanson vous ne participez
pas d'ailleurs aux Victoires de la
musique plus envie d'être complice
dites-vous complice de quoi c'est vrai
que ce milieu je connais moi le cinéma
mais je connais un petit peu aussi mais
surtout la musique c'est devenu très
corrompu bon voilà c'est un milieu très
corrompu mais il faut aussi se le dire
parce que notamment nous français on a
un peu tendance à un peu donner des
leçons à tout le monde et la France a un
pays corrompu comme les autres il y a
pas de il y a pas de raison qu'il ne
soit pas d'ailleurs et notamment dans
dans ce milieu là ou c'est pas forcément
une corruption
spectaculaire avec des mallettes de cash
c'est à dire que la corruption c'est
donner quelque chose en échange une
faveur mais ce quelque chose ça peut
être une appartenance à un réseau ça
peut être faire un livre de trois ans
plus tard enfin et ça c'est devenu très
toujours existé je pense et c'est devenu
très très présent et comme j'ai le
sentiment que le milieu s'est resserré
c'est
[Musique]
sur France Inter acheter des streams ça
c'est ça c'est beaucoup vu donc il y a
toute cette
artificialité qui font que la hiérarchie
des artistes certains artistes sont une
importance une visibilité très
importante et tout ça c'est valorisé en
disque d'or donc un sentiment de succès
et qui n'est pas du tout réel donc
évidemment ça met tout en ça éclate un
peu un peu tout ça en tout artificiel
vous vous attirez des inimitiés en
disant cela notamment nombreuses
notamment quand vous vous faites partie
de la troupe des est-ce que
l'ambiance est un peu glaciale par
rapport à aux propos que vous tenez
publiquement non parce qu'en fait j'ai
nombreuses pour rigoler parce que
vraiment je suis pas un lanceur d'alerte
quand ce que je dis c'est c'est très
loin d'être des scouts c'est je le dis
parce que oui voilà parce que moi
je crois que c'est bien de dire les
choses à vivre quitte à se tromper
d'ailleurs je peux dire aussi des
bêtises mais
la langue de bois c'est trop trop
ennuyeux et puis et puis je fais
attention justement à pas
condamner un tel ou un tel c'est plutôt
un système et qui réel c'est à dire que
par exemple aux au contraire
99% des gens sont d'accord avec moi
est-ce que c'est une c'est une évidence
et ce qui pose un problème c'est pas
uniquement de dénoncer pour dénoncer
parce que que qu'une petite caste
prospère il faut encore qu'une autre
soit soit dominée et écraser et c'est ça
qui pose un problème parce que sinon moi
chacun fait ce qu'il veut et ça me
regarde pas sauf quand on empêche
d'autres de d'exercer et comme j'ai la
chance plusieurs parties qui de ceux qui
qui existent un peu médiatiquement je
l'utilise aussi pour en parler on
continue de parler un peu de ce que vous
détestez puis on parlera de ce que vous
aimez après c'est promis les réseaux
sociaux
je les fais mère et de la désinformation
c'est pourtant au départ une forme
d'expression directe justement brute
citoyenne qui ne passent pas par
justement les grandes institutions et
les filtres oui exactement je suis
d'accord avec l'ensemble de ce que c'est
vrai qu'elle mauvais côté là que vous
citez on est tous en plus moi je suis
père de famille donc il y a cette erreur
malheureusement il est assez de raison
de de l'avoir et donc je m'en méfie
énormément mais je trouve que c'est un
outil génial c'est c'est
parfait ça permet à plein de gens de
s'exprimer qui aurait pas pu s'exprimer
alors évidemment comme comme tous les
outils
ça a plusieurs fonctions c'est à dire
une tronçonneuse on peut couper un arbre
mais on peut aussi découper ses voisins
quoi donc c'est c'est le principe des
réseaux aussi donc je pense qu'il faut
être méfiant mais mais en effet par
rejeter le truc bêtement moi je
l'utilise mais par exemple j'ai pas mes
réseaux et Jésus non pas TikTok pas tous
les réseaux donc non parce que ma fille
m'a fait comprendre que c'était un peu
la honte si j'allais sur tik
pour pour Instagram dernièrement là on
parle du virtuel mais de manière
générale vous êtes quand même plutôt
dans la vraie vie avec les vrais gens
vous défendez le vrai contact même au
sens charnel j'ai envie de dire vous
êtes concert vous êtes très festival
vous avez du terriblement souffrir
pendant le covid ça a été curieux alors
après avec beaucoup de réserves parce
que évidemment moi je fais partie des
privilégiés j'ai passé le covid dans le
sud dans une grande maison donc c'est
c'était très supportable mais c'est vrai
que ça m'a mais comme beaucoup d'entre
nous moi je viens de la scène j'ai
commencé par les bistrots donc c'est
vraiment ce parcours là et ce rapport
est indispensable pour moi ce que c'est
un peu la validation de ce que j'ai fait
depuis 6 mois à chaque fois et ça a été
ça m'a profondément bousculé de de pas
avoir cette validation du public ça
rendait tout un peu 20 un peu abstrait
tu reçois une chanson une personne la
chante ou l'écoute même si c'est Mistral
Gagnant ça ça n'existe pas en fait et
vous avez même fait douter oui comme ça
m'a troublé beaucoup et puis je pense
que ça m'a fait progresser parce que
j'ai mais je travaille un peu des
différemment depuis le covid pour mieux
comprendre qui vous êtes aujourd'hui il
faut remonter à votre enfant et à vos
origines une enfance tranquille
relativement classique petite
bourgeoisie de banlieue parisienne
dites-vous messe le dimanche vous avez
été enfant de cœur joueur de trompette à
l'église scout de France vos
grands-parents vous ont beaucoup marqué
ont beaucoup marqué votre environnement
d'enfants je pense notamment à vos
grands-parents italiens dont vous parlez
souvent je ne l'ai pas encore dit mais
votre vrai nom c'est Nicolini Bruno
Nicolini votre grand-mère catholique
pratiquant vous portez d'ailleurs je
crois peut-être l'avez-vous aujourd'hui
à votre coup ça médaille de la vierge
Marie votre grand-père communiste
tailleur de pierre tombale on sent que
vos grands-parents ont compté dans votre
vie c'est tout votre univers d'enfance
qui vous fait défendre les gens
ordinaires et chez vous le mot ordinaire
surtout pas un gros mot c'est vraiment
ça qui vous fait parler de ces gens dont
personne ne parle mais vous vous en
parlez
l'ordinaire pour les pour les snobs
c'est la réalité des dérisoirs des
autres et l'ordinaire les snob aussi
vivent un ordinaire c'est avec
l'ordinaire c'est la c'est la réalité
finalement et puis moi ça me mais il
comprit dans la littérature c'est je
j'adore le réalisme le naturalisme la
chanson française réaliste c'est quand
même c'est on a une grande tradition de
de cette chanson là qui raconte quelque
chose y compris chez les rappeurs
d'ailleurs qu'on qu'on qui sont ceux qui
ont repris ce flambeau là le lien entre
Fréhel et les rappeurs avec une chanson
très très populaire très
prolétaire et moi j'adore ça donc c'est
une question de goût aussi de goût
raconter la réalité puis et puis en vie
c'est le rendre justice leur rendre
hommage aussi oui
sur la longueur ce côté classe moyenne
donc dont je viens j'ai compris que ça
fait partie des
[Musique]
un peu
bon ça peut être la drogue etc mais
aussi c'est c'est ce sont des choses
assez qu'il faut savoir gérer encore une
fois sans me plaindre parce que c'est à
l'allure de celui que vous êtes
aujourd'hui que diriez-vous au jeune
garçon que vous étiez que que lui
diriez-vous avant qu'il ne se lance dans
la vraie vie dans la vie
je dirais je pense que c'est un peu ce
que j'ai dit
à mes gosses et notamment un grand fils
qui a 18 ans maintenant donc en plein
dedans ce que doivent dire d'ailleurs
tous les parents c'est-à-dire valoriser
le train enfin le bonheur bien sûr mais
le travail
essayer de faire ses propres erreurs pas
faire les erreurs des autres
essayer d'avoir si possible quand même
un petit peu de mauvais caractère parce
que ça permet ça c'est indépendance j'y
crois beaucoup la liberté je crois pas
trop parce que bon
ça c'est un autre sujet mais au moins on
peut essayer d'interdépendant et souvent
quand vous me dit que vous avez mauvais
caractère c'est uniquement vous avez du
caractère en fait donc ça déplaît
forcément après faut pas être le roi des
casse-couilles parce que sinon c'est
insupportable à vivre mais
c'est bien de faire ses propres erreurs
quitte à faire des erreurs encore une
fois c'est pas quelque chose l'échec est
pas quelque chose qui me qui me terrifie
moi du tout
c'est même quelque chose je pense qu'il
faut qu'il faut embrasser
il faut en vivre vous n'étiez pas parti
pour faire de la musique au départ vous
commencez comme technicien régisseur sur
des tournages puis réalisateur de courts
métrages scénariste pour la télévision
vous commencez à écrire des chansons il
y a eu aussi ce duo de clown que vous
créez pas de choix et Barnabé d'ailleurs
Barnabé qui est donc l'envers de Bénabar
et j'ai pas trouvé grand chose sur vos
études un bac B un voyage aux États-Unis
pas d'étude après le bac non je savais
que j'allais pas faire des tubes c'est
je me sentais pas du tout
non c'était j'ai eu mon bac en sans
redoubler c'est un peu le deal que
j'avais avec ma mère
et donc j'ai jamais redoublé j'ai eu mon
bac et puis je j'avais pas trop quoi
faire donc j'étais prendre la langue aux
États-Unis et après j'étais apprenti
photographe enfin vaguement heureusement
je ne suis plus photographe et puis
après j'ai commencé à travailler je
crois qu'il y avait besoin de travailler
de me confronter à la réalité mais
c'était sans j'ai eu depuis ce complexe
de pas avoir fait d'études de alors vos
enfants ou leur dit de faire des études
ou pas je leur conseille de faire des
études et
en effet et j'aurais parlé du côté
autodidacte c'est pas forcément parce
qu'on a un peu tendance vous savez comme
les vedettes qui vont qui vont dire la
télé que eux ils étaient cancre moi j'ai
jamais je me permettrai de dire ça d'une
part je n'étais pas mais surtout ça ça
dit au gosse c'est à dire bah oui vous
pouvez être cancre obligé de travailler
à l'école quoi ou tous ceux qui vont
nous emmerder parce qu'ils arrêtent de
se droguer il s'arrête de boire ça dit
aussi à un enfant que en fait on peut se
droguer est une vedette et puis
s'arrêter et puis ça va bien alors que
c'est pas la vérité en plus en plus
c'est pas la vérité eux ça les permet de
se faire mousser et c'est pas du tout
c'est pas du tout vrai et je trouve que
c'est un poison qu'on qu'on déclare aux
plus jeunes leur truc c'est d'éviter de
se droguer évidemment de pas les juger
s'ils le font mais d'éviter au plus vite
à dire on peut se droguer pendant une
vie puis après on pourra dire dans le
journal à quel point on en est sorti etc
c'est euh ce sont pas des bonnes et donc
moi je me méfie quand je parle de
d'autodidacte c'est bien de faire des
études aussi
le point commun entre tout ça c'est
quand même l'écriture l'envie
crit alors on va parler un peu texte on
va parler écriture mais cette fois avec
ce document que je vais vous présenter
qui vient de nos partenaires les
Archives nationales je vais vous le lire
pour le public qui est obligé mes
lunettes mais voilà et c'est moi qui ai
chargé de la lecture de toute façon il y
a des gens qui nous écoutent donc c'est
vraiment de l'autre côté des documents
qui datent du 22 janvier 1947 il s'agit
d'une lettre assassine adressée au
ministère de la justice par le cartel
d'action morale et sociales demandant la
condamnation de l'éditeur et de
l'imprimeur du livre J'irai cracher sur
vos tombes écrit par le poète parolier
écrivain Boris Vian mais publié sous le
pseudonyme qu'il avait pris alors Vernon
Sullivan je cite cette lettre parce
qu'elle est incroyable ouvrage
excessivement dangereux qui se lit
facilement même par des adolescents très
peu cultivées tiens tiens il est dans
sadisme et d'un réalisme révoltant il
est susceptible de pousser des
adolescents au délice sexuel et au
meurtre pour la petite histoire après
une série de procès Boris Vian sera
condamné à 15 jours de prison plusieurs
années plus tard mais il sera
vitaministier et le scandale va quand
même faire exploser les ventes de ses
ouvrages qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire à
vous le parolier à celui
moi je suis trompé 10 donc ça me fait
mal personnel mais mais bon il y a des
trucs comme ça donc alors on en est pas
là et puis ils ont le droit ils aiment
pas les cuivre et un mec il aime pas les
filles j'aime pas les cuves mais c'est
ça ça fait partie et il y a plein de
petites choses comme ça et donc en effet
j'ai été pas du tout quand j'étais
scénariste pour H parce qu'au contraire
là on pouvait faire ce qu'on voulait
mais après depuis les scénaristes les
scénarios auxquels j'ai participé il y a
eu ce problème là que c'est posé comment
vous les caractériseriez vos textes
de la pudeur des scènes du quotidien
comment vous est-ce que est-ce qu'elle a
est-ce qu'on peut la définir votre
écriture
je crois que c'est une écriture assez
académique
c'est vrai il y a plusieurs courants
dans la chanson et la chanson m'ont dit
réaliste qui est très écrite couplée
refrain si possible avec une chute avec
un personnage qui revient qui se
développe de coupler en couplet tu as
une il y a une écriture d'aujourd'hui
qui me gêne un peu plus ou il y a plus
de 3e couplet je parle comme un vieux
con mais 53 ans j'assume et parce que le
troisième couplet était souvent un peu
la synthèse des deux premiers enfin
c'est les trois actes en fait du théâtre
et en rajoutant si possible une une
morale ou une chute c'est très classique
c'est très classique mais ça c'est vrai
pour Renault pour pour
plein de chanteurs
Thomas Fersen que j'aime beaucoup enfin
très nombreux et puis ça c'est dans une
tradition vraiment de chancelier en fait
si on prend le dîner par exemple sorti
en 2005 dans l'album reprise des
négociations les paroles semble toute
simple mais l'universalité du message
est frappante et c'est probablement ce
qui a fait évidemment le succès de ce
titre on s'en fout on y va pas on a qu'à
se cacher sous les draps on commandera
des pizzas toi la télé et moi on
s'appelle on s'excuse on improvise on
trouve quelque chose on a qu'à dire à
tes amis qu'on les aime pas et puis tant
pis ce qui est fou dans ce texte c'est
que ce sont des scènes qu'on a tous vécu
tous pensés et c'est dit c'est tellement
universel c'est probablement ça qui a
fait le succès de ce texte d'ailleurs
vous arrivez à formuler ce que des
choses des choses que nous vivons tous
mais que nous n'arrivons pas à
verbaliser c'est ça votre force
peut-être moi j'ai du mal à avoir un
regard un peu pertinent sur mon propre
boulot moi je sais que je passe beaucoup
de temps à
me méfier comme de la peste de la de la
poésie politisante d'accord
trop trop facile je suis malheureux elle
est partie je suis triste et toi est-ce
que tu es triste tous ces trucs là qui
peuvent être d'ailleurs parfois très
beaucoup fait très très bien fait
d'ailleurs et c'est quand même une forme
de facilité c'est plus difficile
d'écrire sur le quotidien finalement oui
et puis avec des mots et puis je crois
vraiment que la poésie est aussi dans le
quotidien moi je c'est pas qu'une
posture c'est que je crois que vraiment
qu'elle doit poésie dans un abribut
c'est dans un et dans un train de
banlieue je le pense vraiment dans un
brosse à dents c'est je le crois je le
crois vraiment c'est peut-être ça qui
passe alors vous qui aimez les textes
les chansons à texte moi j'ai envie de
vous lire ces paroles et vous allez me
dire si vous reconnaissez l'artiste et
peut-être même le titre et si vous aimez
toi tu es bon qu'à planer ouais je sens
tu as le seum j'ai la Bocca entre nous
il y a un fossé toi tu es bon qu'à faire
la mala bébé fait du sale à l'eau à
l'eau à l'eau million dollars bébé tube
vaut ça bébé fait du sale à l'eau à
l'eau à l'eau Million Dollar bébé tu
bossa Nakamura
c'est son titre Pookie elle est aut la
compositrice interprète franco-malienne
et je vous en parle parce que beaucoup
se moquent de ces textes se moquent de
sa façon d'écrire disent qu'on ne
comprend rien et pourtant elle cartonne
est-ce que vous vous y voyez un paradoxe
c'est ce qu'elle a sa façon elle aussi
d'écrire des choses très simples du
quotidien aussi des histoires d'amour
des choses comme ça comment vous voyez
ça vous qui parlez aussi du quotidien
d'une toute autre façon évidemment je
sentais que ça s'adresse vraiment à des
personnes qui le comprennent parce que
moi je comprends pas la moitié en fait
du du truc mais c'est passionnant parce
que c'est c'est sûr que des mots comme
ça finiront d'ailleurs dans le dans le
dictionnaire c'est à dire que on le sait
tous la langue française elle est faite
pour évoluer mais
ils sont pas dans un texte pour que vous
l'écoutiez vous pouvez aussi vous
laisser porter par la musique parce que
c'est ça il y Aya Nakamura par exemple
moi je décroche assez vite c'est pour ça
que la musique anglo-saxonne j'ai j'ai
écouté enfin ou italienne quelle qu'elle
soit mais pas longtemps parce que moi
j'ai besoin qu'on me raconte une
histoire mais c'est vraiment un goût
personnel c'est de comprendre ce qu'on
me raconte et sinon il y a des trucs
magnifiques on parlait de Bashung c'est
magnifique mais à un moment j'ai pas
assez à manger dans dans l'histoire
elle-même et Dieu sait si Bashung c'est
déjà un énorme niveau j'ai des photos à
vous présenter Bénabar la première la
voici
c'est Indochine groupe qui a fait parler
de lui récemment refusant de participer
au festival Les Déferlantes qui avaient
envisagé de se produire à Perpignan une
ville gérée par le rassemblement
national Louise Attaque a menacé du même
boycott finalement donc le festival ne
se produira pas à perpétine à Perpignan
comment avez-vous regardé cette cette
affaire est-ce que vous auriez fait
pareil est-ce qu'un artiste doit
s'engager jusque là ou pas ça m'est
arrivé un truc comme ça sur il y a deux
tournées dans une ville où qui était
contre enfin l'équipe dirigeante était
notoirement d'extrême droite et contre
la le mariage pour tous et puis avec un
discours avec certains relents
homophobes et
on ne savait pas quand on est producteur
avait signé et donc ça nous a posé un
problème moi j'ai été joué j'ai été joué
parce que
moi je choisis pas le public et puis il
y a une différence entre public mais par
contre le mon cachet c'est à 100% de ce
que j'ai reçu je l'ai donné
à l'association Le Refuge vous savez où
il y a les jeunes quand ils se font
virer de chez eux parce que parce qu'ils
sont gays et voilà c'était ma façon à
moi donc moi je voulais pas être
militant de quoi que ce soit parce que
ce sont des gens qui sont élus je suis
la République avant de avant tout et
donc on est élu on est élu et ça c'est
quand même il va quand même falloir que
tout le monde se fasse à cette raison là
avec les RN qui a semé nationale c'est
c'est vrai donc c'est sinon
interdire le vote quand il convient pas
parce que moi évidemment je m'oppose à
ce qu'il propose mais et donc voilà moi
je l'ai géré comme ça une deuxième photo
c'est Michel Sardou qu'on ne présente
pas non plutôt classé à droite vous avez
confié un jour que vous aimiez bien ces
chansons et que vous aviez même eu un
temps envie de reprendre l'un de ces
titres et que c'était des copains qui
vous en avez dissuadé et que vous le
regrettez vous auriez aimé reprendre
quel titre par exemple il y a des titres
comme une passion pour la java de
Broadway d'ailleurs je j'en ai fait une
petite sœur mais en le disant qui
s'appelle Paris baynight mais c'était au
début de ma carrière dans les bistrots
c'est il y avait dans les années 90
moi j'étais déjà décomplexé complètement
et j'ai toujours beaucoup aimé mais j'ai
le Sardou pour les chansons elles-mêmes
après les pistes de prise de position
Spirit
des chansons depuis on a compris qu'il y
a beaucoup plus de il y a beaucoup de
provoques mais quand j'ai commencé
j'étais très très fier parce qu'on
m'avait comparé à Michel Sardou dans le
monde
quand le monde s'intéresse à moi donc ça
fait il y a longtemps déjà
complètement ouais ça fait partie des
choses dont on dit il y a des listes
noires vous savez dans le truc noir
il y a des vous savez maintenant dans
dans le petit milieu dont on parlait
c'est un milieu qui ne fait que
revendiquer l'appartenance à ce propre
milieu en fait et d'ailleurs il y a des
gens très bien mais qui qui se qui se
maintiennent c'est le prof des
aristocraties c'est qu'on se tient sinon
on tombe tous
et moi je suis farouchement républicain
justement moi je déteste les
aristocraties et donc dans le monde il y
avait comparé au Sardou de gauche
alors moi j'étais hyper fier et puis en
fait les attachés de tresses on dit mais
non c'est pas un compliment c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle
parce que moi je voulais qu'on mette
partout vous savez sur les trucs
de gauche et non non c'était pas un
compliment manifestement mais moi je
l'ai pris comme tel vous n'êtes pas sur
la liste noire de public c'est non en
tout cas vous le voyez mais d'abord on
est on arrive à la fin de cette émission
on a une question rituelle qui concerne
les statues qui nous entourent dans ce
lieu magique qui est le dôme Tournon
nous sommes entourés d'une statue qui
représente la sagesse d'une autre qui
représente la prudence d'une autre qui
représente la justice et celle derrière
moi qui représente l'éloquence quelle
est la vertu dont vous avez envie de
nous parler là maintenant tout de suite
ah bah tout de suite je dirais oui
l'éloquence l'éloquence parce que c'est
tellement central et le monde éloquence
parfois et puis ça rejoint aussi quelque
chose qui m'obsède c'est la les fake
news et justement des gens qui sont
parfois très éloquents mais pour dire
des de pure mensonges et d'ailleurs faut
faudrait le le dire en français une fake
news ça s'appelle un mensonge c'est
pourquoi il y a une espèce de mot
intermédiaire comme pour la relativiser
oui c'est ça comme c'était moins grave
en fait c'est juste une fake news et ça
je trouve ça terrifiant et évidemment
pour nous mais pour les gamins c'est
tous les les informations complètement
erronées ou fallacieuses qui sont pas
complètement
fausses comme si les gens vous disent
non mais il y a du vrai aussi dans ce
truc là bah oui il y a du vrai mais
c'est comme si on disait un assassin il
est mardi il a pas tué bah oui il a pas
tué oui il y a du vrai mais c'est pas un
assassin 24 heures sur 24 si on est
inventeur aujourd'hui le monde
médiatique c'est c'est un jacuzzi quoi
on s'arrêtera sur cette phrase sur cette
belle image
jacuzzi j'espère que j'ai pas crever
tout de suite après ça sera ma dernière
phrase
merci en tout cas merci beaucoup Bénabar
d'avoir été notre invité dans cette
belle émission merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi comme chaque semaine on se
retrouve n'oubliez pas que cette
émission est aussi à retrouver en
podcast merci à très vite sur Public
Sénat
[Musique]